volete qualcosa di brutto lorenzo fi
veramente schifo
non bastava lorenzo cesa brutto di
persone non ce la vedo proprio povero
povero lorenzo notice per un po ma va
allora si chiama il mio mondo allora non
mi ricordavo più allora va bene il fuoco
amico è presente ben carica mondo eccolo
quadro di cosa come si gioca anche io ho
fame le entrate lo fame meno male che
sono entrato io voi non siete ancora
entrati quindi posso aiace
mi ero lasciato in una condizione così
pet pessima ma ci sono i barili nelle
nelle trappole per giovani sono squalo e
ricordatevi al cielo scuola di vento
salta saltare sull'acqua come gesù c'era
una scolara niente salta sul lato ma lei
stiamo a qualcuno di voi ha notato che
stiamo dormendo delle tecniche ciao
va bene allora se ci giochiamo bene le
nostre carte qualcuno pensi ragazzi mi
ricorda il preside mettere la coca e
vero c'e ragione con l'uomo mettiamo
all'acqua non sbaglia che bevo l'acqua
del mare cristo cioè io buone st acquah
tedeschi ma nella falla quando stato per
fare letti mettono la plastica come l'ha
detto un secondo fa ci si augura che per
fare bene dice la plastica la pasta
altre tre cucine tre griglie semplici
una la faccio io l'ho già fatta io farne
altre due griglie semplice quindi quali
e fare altre due bravo pietro o che
hanno fatto e 2 dove la metto nei fatti
nei fatti e 2 mettere qualcosa dietro
dietro questi cavalca lo squalo mamma
mia cosa ci troverà interessante l'inter
possiamo provare a fare le cose per
scappare dal maestro molto ragazzo
guardate qua
mammamia tripadvisor match è il adesivo
di tripadvisor da mentre sulla piazza
comuni che abbiano legal cambiano il
gabbiano piano filo martello io
fra lotta a martellarlo ha mangiato per
queste cose ma sono patate sono le mie
patate allora io vorrei fare 1600 retini
quanti chiodi potete farmi che lì si
fanno con i rottami 2 rottami fanno tre
chiodi ma tutto quanto da te la destra
aver alzato la testa la dottoressa papa
il card lavora ma dov'è e sopra sopra e
sopra orbo e lo rendono poi le cose per
fare migliorano la alle travi
no no ai ottavi
in realtà vigenti o poi che macchione
sono io pensi un cupido fluttuanti
l'oleodotto ecco ecco ecco il karma
ciccio guardate guarda mia fin dove di
questo che ho fatto quasi fallo dalla
parte opposta copiare e fanno e due a
uno davanti all'altro così allora ogni
rettino deve avere un terreno per
costruirne un altro poi dopo quindi tu
così io così scortino tu fai una di
queste ok palla un'altra cosa
si guarda così un'altra seria mobileye
dall'altra parte ha preparato ok ora
dovremmo ricoprirle di quella che stai
facendo tu dovremmo ricoprirle ci
servono un botto di assi perché così
almeno lo squalo non li colpisce che
cosa è a madonna quante cose
grazie grazie amici grazie ai 12 gradi
si è questa roba incredibile abbiamo già
coperto tutto perfetto ha d'altra parte
siamo a posto dormiamo via pietro ai a
iasi perché man dobbiamo coprire ancora
stato praticamente 9 st in 40 di esse è
perché teli stagione risorgendo media è
da meno mi servono per coprire bravo
cene oltre 90 gizio bravo era e aspetta
che questa aveva 20 anni sono gli eventi
però non lo so ho visto tanto cibo
locale al pana
io penso d'arrivo e tu perché per le
cose sky ragazza abbiamo fatto in crea
ogni volta possiamo fare un retino entro
facciamolo per capire temi facciamo più
roba raccogliamo e più siamo ricchi
sto per schiantarmi sull'isola ragazzi
tipo lost d occhio
io ci ho proprio la passerella per
salirci quadra che quanto utile stati
noi abbiamo ci distrugge tutto sono un
deficiente e porta la catenina pagaia
velocissimi una pagaia veloci veloci
veloci la cina paga gli abbia prego
giocandoci dalla barca facendo perno
sull'isola perché se non andiamo abbiamo
i retini a sfavore di di oggetti colori
e un contadino nato ha detto marini
finita dietro da quando io sono uno che
fa miracoli ma io ce l'ho da una vita
ciò anche se minima di voti la metà
piano di sopra la palma si pentì la
pianti sarà severamente [ __ ] hai finito
di la bravo guarda ora che abbiamo fatto
è stato fatto un acrobata cosa è la
madonnina era esatto è una portaerei
quanto abbiamo ampliato e parliamo sono
orgoglioso di rari sì vorrei fare del
sesso dopo cosa tanto emerge io sono
pronto
guarda poi lasciata a letto solo ci sono
in mezzo ai ecco qua c g
ma perché tu fai lo fai con una cosa è
una specie di è un sadomaso crearsi ai
vero è mai stato vaso capisco faccio io
sto addio quello martello queste sono
sono sono metodi alternativi
se voglio anche altro
no quello non lo so se forse meno
pesante meno male che de gustibus esatto
esatto de gustibus perché sarà un casino
pure ma norme può la madonna grande
occhio all'isola
dobbiamo fare una cortesia pietro non
dobbiamo impattarla se non ci giriamo ed
è un casino poi dobbiamo solo passarci
leggermente di fianco devi andare dalla
parte ecco vedi dove siamo ora dalla
parte opposta e devi girarla e poi con
la pagaia va indietro perché vedi dove
la scala nostra come ci arrivo lì
non toccarla da che se ci giriamo non
toccare la toccava non toccherà non
toccarla non toccarla quanto sei dio
sì perché sta contro i retini idiota
ci stiamo girando li mortacci tua
madonna di dio più a destra destra che
sono impattiamo professori che mi palle
guarda dove sono
devo arrivare su no no come ci arrivo
sono superman per fai il bravo proprio
ok bravi due ore e mezzo ma ciò ce
l'abbiamo fatto ciao amore ciao esatto
l'avevo giudicata faide che bella e
bellissima all'isola ma cosa fa la palma
lega non ha capito chi parla quando sei
solo e che non riesco a capire un attimo
stava ti affascina molto da barba
crescente non so se per adesso guarda
questi mini anas che non solo li hamas
piccoli ma semplicemente è la texture
nell'anas grande maestro piccolo ma che
dici è vero hanno rimpicciolito la
strada per ragazzi e come se mettessero
per fare un neonato nato your own site
quei ragazzi abbiamo ampliato di bestia
la zattera per raccogliere tutto ciò
passiamo adesso possiamo fare di tutto
anche piano di sopra fighissimo
stiamo migliorando però tanta roba
secondo me ci siamo
credo possiamo tami crasto una maglietta
decente senza scollatura però vabbè però
e vedesse per cento ragazzi nel senso
che recentemente mi piace di casa anche
pietre cc per aver partecipato non si sa
se non esistere non ci vediamo a faccia
[Musica]